when you finish your record did you hear
some part of yourself you maybe hadn't
heard before after you were done with it
yeah I think to have a cohesive piece of
work that was actually kind of like this
tapestry
of kind of like the roller coaster of
girlhood that I'd been on through my
whole 20s and like all you know like
every single song is about a someone or
a somebody or us you know and it was
like it was like being able to see this
whole kind of unraveling of of a period
time did it feel like a memoir kind of
yeah yeah one thing I feel like so much
had happened in those 10 years yeah
um I've been in a lot of ups and downs
and coming into myself I had to like
memorialize that that those 10 years I
feel like to kind of be set free into
into the next decade